[Music]
hi my name is Tom Edgington I'm a
supervisor here at the Universal Studios
sign and graphics department this
machine allows us to print on several
different types of material to create
some of these replicas we're using our
latex print technology printing directly
to vellum to print set plan replicas
from Jurassic Park 3 from the original
set plan scans
[Music]
I'm Tony cope we are making a mold on
this baby Velociraptor I put him in clay
to the halfway point we box it up and we
pour a two-part silicone I had to cut
the legs off because it was really hard
to mold it with all the legs and arms on
it so they're getting molded
individually put them in here
clay them up real nice for the top on
this pour silicone then tomorrow we'll
be ready to make parts
my name is Frank Ramirez I work here at
Universal Studios or just finished
primary in this thing and I'm getting
ready to start layering it so that we
can get to this point each one's going
to be different even though they're all
gonna look the same just because they're
hand-painted and doing a transparent
wash line if it gets into these little
crevices that you see you want that
realistic book I'm just mixing my colors
as I go a couple different colors here
they're not the painted areas but they
still want that green coming through on
this eye we're trying to get it as
realistic as I can right now I'm just
putting a semi clear on the eyeball
[Music]
there you have it
[Music]
with this printer we're able to print
the universal logo directly onto the
wood for our crates
hey I'm Blaire heisting and I'm the
supervising scenic artist for the
Universal Studio sign check this far it
was the crate that we're gonna build to
put this electable in each crate has its
own foam insert to protect your
collectible from getting damaged during
shipping
[Music]
[Music]